You are fluent in a foreign language, when you know at least 20.000 words.
Oh..
You are fluent in a foreign language when you can tackle any topic at the drop of a hat
Ehm..
You are fluent in a language when you can speak a language perfectly.
Aaaah..
Hi, my name is Luca, from Lucalampariello.com
and today I am going to tackle
the beautiful and much debated concept of fluency in a foreign language.
Let's get started.
It is astounding and quite surprising to see
how differently people see a single word in the English language,
and that is fluency.
For a lot of people fluency
is strictly connected with the amount of words
that you know in a language.
So, some people think that
the more words you know, the more fluent you are.
But things are a little bit more nuanced than that.
There are 2 main points I wanted to address in this regard.
First of all, native speakers and non native speakers
tend to use just a small fraction
of the existing vocabulary in a language.
So the first point I wanted to address is that
non native as well as native speakers of a specific language
actually use just a small portion
of the existing vocabulary in any language.
Now, you might be wondering why and how
it is possible that native and non native speakers
use just a small fraction of the existing vocabulary in a foreign language.
For example, are we talking about
dozens, hundreds or thousands of words?
The reality is
it does not really matter,
but what matters is that
we tend to use a small fraction of the existing words
because we work in NETWORKS.
So, if you know, say, 1000 words,
you can come up with hundreds or thousands
of possible combinations,
that is, sentences,
to get your point across.
So, for example, if I conjure up the word "heart"
you might have in your head - if you are a native English speaker -
hundreds..maybe not hundreds but dozens of expressions
related to the word "heart",
which is a common word.
For example "from the bottom of my heart"
"This is not for the fainted hearted",
"at the heart of the matter"
"Heart of gold"
"Heart of stone"
So, as you can see - and this goes for a lot of common and uncommon words -
there is always a constellation of elements
surrounding that word.
And what happens is that native speakers,
and you can see it in a 5 or 6 year old kid -
don't know that many words, but
they can arrange them like (adult) native spekers would,
so forming sentences and expressions
that are commonly used in a foreign language.
That means being fluent in a language.
Some years ago, when I was in Russia,
the organizer of a conference I participated in and myself
decided to make a few short videos in Russian,
and it turned out that, at a certain point,
when we were shooting live, filming live,
I could not remember the word "combination (mixture) of", that is "смесь" in Russian.
And I remember that someone wrote in the comment section below
- a very nice place -
that I "didn't speak Russian well" or "fluently"
because "I didn't know such a common word".
So, going back to what I was saying before,
this is not just a matter of knowing one word or not knowing one word,
but the point here is that
fluency is not a line that you cross,
so either you are fluent or you are not fluent,
there are a lot of different degrees of fluency
because fluency at the end of the day
is just a continuous line.
What we do for the sake of simplicity is
to distinguish 3 main phases of fluency,
so there is a continous spectrum of fluency,
but we mainly divide it into
elementary, intermediate and advanced,
and each and everyone of these phases corresponds to different abilities,
and I am still referring to spoken fluency.
And another thing that you have to remember is that
fluency - the quality and the quantity of fluency -
depends on your path.
Native speakers have all the same path more or less,
but the truth is, adults learn in different ways,
so the channels, the people, the things you do, the materials
they all have an impact on the degree,
quality and quantity of fluency,
so never forget that what you do
impacts who you are.
Now that I told you what fluency is NOT
let me give you my own personal definition of fluency.
To me, spoken fluency is
the linguistic ability, combined with cultural awareness,
to confidently and smoothly communicate
with native speakers in a meaningful way.
That querulous and fatuous roué enervated me to no end,
at every party, he wanted to be the cynosure".
Well, first of all
I hoped I pronounced it well,
and second of all,
what the heck did I just read?!
As you can see,
these are actually words that exist in the English language -
from querulous to fatuous,
but they are less common, so they are less used.
There are synonyms of these words,
but how many times have you heard these words
even if you are a native English speaker?
That goes to show that
fluency is a RELATIVE PHENOMENON,
as I was saying before,
we don't know and we can't use
all the existing words in a spoken language,
there are words that are very uncommon,
there are words that are used in specialized fields,
and there even words that are common,
but that have uncommon connotations of meaning.
This goes to show that
every language is a huge, immense ocean to explore.
We will never explore all of it.
Nobody knows a language perfectly.
And that's fine!
The final and ultimate goal
is always to communicate,
so if you even know a tiny fraction of a language
it is fine, as long as you can use that knowledge well,
you can put it to use to communicate effectively.
THAT is what fluency really is.
So there you have it.
In a nutshell,
fluency is NOT just about the words that you know,
but first and foremost how you use them.
Fluency is not a line that you cross,
so one day you are fluent
and the other day you are not fluent or the other way around,
but it is more like a continuous line
that has no boundaries and
it can mainly be divided into
the three stages of elementary, intermediate and advanced fluency.
And ultimately, fluency is a relative phenomenon,
fluency means to use well your language
in order to communicate with other human beings.
It is not about knowing a language perfectly,
because at the end of the day
nobody, not even native speakers
know their own language perfectly.
So the bottom line of all this is that
if you want to be truly fluent in a foreign language,
you have to focus on the process of becoming fluent.
You have to talk, read out loud, to read books
to watch documentaries, movies,
to go out with your friends, to live experiences..
You have to make it happen in real life.
That is what fluency is all about: living.
So, as usual, if you want to know more
please on the link in the description box
there is a huge post waiting for you
with a lot of practical steps that I did not include in this video,
and hopefully I will see you there,
feel free to drop comments and interact with me.
Again, thanks a bunch for watching
and see you very soon here on YouTube.